this year of women in film I am here to
present an award for a category in which
women have traditionally found it
difficult to gain a toehold Best
Supporting Actor I think it can be
safely said however that this year was a
breakthrough year in this category more
ways than one there are five
performances of such singular skill and
originality that they are virtually
incomparable however they wouldn't
accept my pleas for a five-way tie so
here goes
the nominees for Best Supporting Actor
are J Davidson in The Crying Game
Gene Hackman in Unforgiven
Jack Nicholson and a few good men
Al Pacino in Glengarry Glen Ross
David Paymer and mr. Saturday night and
the Oscar goes to gene Hackman and
Unforgiven
thank you very much quick thanks to
david valdez producer david peoples our
writer hello boy
all the wonderful actors richard harris
morgan freeman frances fisher and
especially to Clint who kind of made it
all possible for me and for everyone
else in the film it was a wonderful
experience
I'd like to dedicate my part of this
evening to my uncle Orrin Hackman he was
wonderful guy thank you very much
you